very warm one temperatures are going to
be above normal as we get through the
week
you know they were warm for the weekend
86 on saturday 81 yesterday
we did have all those clouds that kind
of pushed in and they hung around
yesterday but those have already moved
out and that should give us clear
viewing for some uh stargazing at night
so tonight and tomorrow just about an
hour after sunset if you look to the
northwest sky
you should see uh the crescent moon set
up with some star clusters so
a pleiades and then aldebaran and should
be just really pretty you know i just
always like to look to the sky and kind
of see a lot of times you look out there
and you go hmm what is that what am i
looking at well if you look out there
tonight and tomorrow you'll know what it
is should be a beautiful sight keep some
clear skies to get out there and do some
star gazing temperatures are a mix of
50s and low 60s this morning centennial
hill 61 same for the strip green valley
at 60. 58 for henderson 58 for
mountain's edge red rock in the mid 50s
and we've had some breezes up in the
mountains already we're going to get
more of those through the day and then
the valley gets the wind tomorrow as a
cold front makes its way through
southern nevada that'll help knock back
these extra warm afternoon temps we'll
have up in cedar city it's chilly 34 35
over in lincoln county cali any look at
ely at 25 total positive 42 reno at 43
we've got 40s in indian springs 52 in
perum 57 in boulder city and laughlin's
at 64 right now so we should be right in
the mid 70s for early april instead
we're just going to leave those behind
before noontime and get right into upper
80s today wow extra warm 90s are the
records for the month of april and we
will get real close to those records a
couple of times maybe this week so let's
go to the east side of the country we've
got more winter weather with snow and
freezing rain up around the great lakes
and then showers and even some
thunderstorms through the midwest the
mid-south and down into the southern
plains back into the west it's all about
the wind we've got high wind warnings
all these areas of red fire weather
warnings down around the four corners
and also some winter weather advisories
the system that's now pushing into the
oregon and washington area is bringing
snow and rain that's great news we're
not looking for that we're looking for a
cold front though tomorrow that's
associated with that system and that's
what will bring us the wind and then
change our temperatures so 87 today 76
as i said is normal we'll go all the way
to 90 tomorrow but those northwest winds
could be up to 30 miles an hour behind
that front boy things drop right back to
81 and then we build that warmth right
back to the 90s even 93 on saturday more
wind early next week so a bit of a
roller coaster for beginning of april